bienvenue à questions d'info alors à
sept mois de la présidentielle à droite
se met en ordre de marche avec le
lancement c'est aujourd'hui mercredi le
lancement officiel de la primaire
économie identité sécurité qu'est ce qui
va qu'est-ce qui doit peser
qu'est-ce qui doit le plus pesé dans la
campagne 2010 est soutien d'alain juppé
françois bayrou le président du modem
qui se prépare au cas où est l'invité de
questions d'info ya les côtés pour vous
interroger monsieur bayod françoise
fressoz du monde frédéric dumoulin de
l'ahp et yaël goosz de france info
bonjour monsieur bayrou
bonjour à l'heure où nous enregistrons
cette émission l'état de santé de
jacques chirac reste très préoccupant
vous avez été ministre sous présidence
chirac de 1995 à 1997
c'était l'époque de la fracture sociale
c'était l'époque du manger des poches
quels souvenirs
quel plus grand souvenir vous gardez de
lui dans ses années de gouvernement
alors dans des moments de très grandes
inquiétudes comme ceux que nous vivons
d'abord pour moi cette un an que je
pense il se trouve que la vie a fait que
j'ai souvent rencontré jacques chirac me
suis parfois j'ai été dans des moments
de tension avec lui vous allez affronter
jeu les affronter mais il se trouve que
la vie a fait que nous avons eu
l'occasion de parler je veux dire
d'hommes et c'est à cet instant là que
moi je ressentais la sensibilité de
l'homme qu'il dissimulait sous une
carapace très très importante il était
blindée il en avait traversé beaucoup
les responsables politiques traverse
beaucoup de
deux moments donc mais au-delà de cette
carapace de ce défense
il y avait un homme il y à un homme très
sensible que la vie n'a pas épargnés et
en quel qualificatif comment on les
filières le premier auquel je pense
c'est un homme qui recherchait l'unité
de son pays la france est et il était il
a essayé d'éviter les fractures les
affrontements les plus importants il n'a
pas hésité à différentes reprises de
revenir sur des réformes
incomprise et même en le critiquer pour
cela et on le moc est pour cela oui je
sais les formules qui ont été utilisés
louis saez et c'est à moi c'est ce ce
n'est pas mon ce n'est pas mon sentiment
est donc le la première chose pour moi
c'est cette volonté de servir au fonds
de préserver la société française des
clivages les plus importants et la
deuxième chose qui est pour moi très
marquante c'est le courage qu'il a eu au
moment de la guerre d'irak
parce qu'il en fallait y avait des
forces considérables qui voulaient
contraindre la france à entrer en guerre
y compris dans la majorité y compris aux
danses et dans les proches
de son gouvernement et donc il y avait
des forces considérables qui voulaient
nous forcer à entrer dans le choix que
les américains avaient fait et il a eu
le courage tranquille et ce coup de dire
non et ce jour là je les soutenais et
j'ai trouvé que il était pour la france
une voix qui a été clair là où on n'est
pas sûr que ses deux successeurs
l'aurait eue
bon je comprenais bien que dans le
moment que nous vivons c'est pas le
moment de réserver son pareil avec ses
successeurs ni de pollen gelée c'est
avec suffisamment de d'alacrité pour
nous paraît mais il ya une sorte
d'unanimité aujourd'hui au tour de
jacques chirac y compris peut-être de la
part de ceux qui clivent la société est
ce que ça vous choque un peu ça cette
récupération
bon la récupération et dans la nature
des choses dans les périodes électorales
alors moi j'essaie de ne pas me prêter
j'essaie de ne pas y participer mais
j'ai suffisamment de connaissances de la
nature humaine pour avoir une idée assez
nette de ce qu'elle cherche à faire si
l'héritier du chiraquisme mon quels sont
les héritiers au pluriel 1 je
n'appartiens pas cette famille politique
j'étais comme vous savez dans l'autre
famille politique dans l'udf de l'époque
et je sais pas moi de distribuer les
brevets d'héritage juppé qui quand même
dans la lignée en héritage en tout cas
il ya une chose certaine c'est que quand
on a posé la question à jacques chirac
lui a répondu en disant le plus proche
de moi c'est alain juppé je vais l'aimer
mais je le comprenais bien je ne veux
pas participer à cette recherche des des
prix de fidélité ou d'héritage ça n'est
pas je trouve que quand de grands
événements se produisent des événements
émouvant pour la nation - ont fait de
récupération et mieux c'est voilà mon
point de vue à moi on vient on en vient
aux primaires justement puisque pas les
acheter françoise fressoz et l'actualité
du jour c'est effectivement les
candidats sélectionnés la primaire la
droite la primaire de la droite n'avait
jamais été très partisan de cet exercice
est-ce que vous maintenez votre position
vous dites bon bah après tout que la
compétition jaillissent le moins que
l'on puisse dire c'est que je ne me
reconnais pas dans cette compétition et
je ne me reconnais pas pour deux raisons
la première c'est que la primaire c'est
reconnaître affiché célébrer la rupture
du pays en deux camps
j'ai toujours été opposé à cette rupture
je pense qu'il ya rien de plus faux que
de prétendre que la vie politique c'est
entre droite et gauche
au moment où nous sommes dans les années
que nous vivons vous voyez bien que ce
qui apparaît de plus important c'est que
la gauche est fracturée et en guerre
civile
la droite fracturée et en guerre civile
et le centre lui-même n'a pas l'unité
qu'il faudrait il est donc
seul qui ait l'air de donald trump
français aujourd'hui c'est marine le pen
ou c'est nicolas non mais vous voyez
bien que ça exploit y est bien la mère
extremis des débats mais c'est pas moi
me legault les rires vous avez vous qui
allez donc vous allez aujourd'hui vers
le nord de la france et ce sera ma
deuxième raison si vous voulez bien mais
la première pour moi ce qui doit dominer
une vie démocratique une vie civique
c'est le pluralisme et le pluralisme
français aujourd'hui il est empêché de
s'exprimer
la primaire est un des instruments voilà
pourquoi je n'y adhère pas le deuxième
c'est que si je ne me trompe pas alain
juppé à une analyse différente de la
mienne on en a beaucoup parlé
c'est vrai beaucoup mais et vous pensez
que pour voir aujourd'hui vous voyez
bien qu'ils expriment vous voyez bien
qu'il a une analyse qui est différente
de la mienne lui pense qu'avec un
électorale arjona arf les plus fidèles
de ce que l'opinion du pays souhaite moi
je trouve que la primaire commence a été
vu aux états unis avec l'élection de
trump qui favorise we7 c'est une machine
à alimenter les surenchères on va avoir
l'occasion d'en parler je ne doute pas
dans cette émission est donc de ce point
de vue là je trouve que ce n'est pas
bienvenu mais c'est une compétition qui
a lieu de cette compétition peuvent
sortir soit un candidat de rassemblement
auquel kg vie je le soutiendrai soit le
choix de la division très forte du pays
auquel cas je ne soutiendrai pas et je
proposerai aux français une autre
alain juppé comment est ce que vous
allez concrètement le soutenir pendant
la campagne de la primaire
simplement dix ans que je pense parce
que vous avez vous posé on vous savez ce
qu'on dit sur vous non à force de dire
je veux dire à force de dire que
l'électorat de la jupe et et centristes
vous êtes auprès de lui vous représentez
une sorte d'épouvantail pour l'électorat
républicain qui va se déporter dans la
jupe et vers nicolas sarkozy monsieur
aziz à 2
il faut que vous mettiez une chose en
tête je sais bien que c'est difficile
parce que quand on fait des commentaires
politiques et des échos politique on
cherche constamment nous pose des
questions on cherche comme et moi je
vous répond directement
on cherche constamment la petite bête un
pur pour essayer d'en faire un événement
je peux vous dire quand vous êtes en
situation de vous présenter à une
élection
vous préférez des gens qui vous
soutiennent que des gens qui ne vous
soutiennent pas que vous vous arrivez à
suivre jusque là mais là on parle et
vous arrivez à le suivre jusque là alors
c'est très simple j'ai exprimé ce fait
qui est un fait politique qui est pas
fréquent dans la vie politique
le nombre c'est presque sans exemple que
responsable politique qui a une assise
conséquente qui représente un courant
d'opinion qui est assez haut dans les
enquêtes d'opinion et qui incarne un
courant politique du pays avec des
intentions de vote sérieuse vous
c'est très rare que responsables
politiques disent je suis prêt à
soutenir encore 105 je suis 100% sincère
c'est à 1000% sincère parce que monsieur
go je vais vous dire une chose
il ya des gens qui racontent des
histoires je n'en suis pas il ya des
gens qui qui passent leur vie à
dissimuler la vérité je n'en suis pas et
si vous regardez tout au long des années
que nous avons passées ensemble vous
comme journaliste et moi comme
responsable politique
vous ne trouverez pas un seul exemple eu
de deux d'ambiguïté je ne suis pas
ambiguë jeudi sans le moindre heurt sans
la moindre zone grise que si ce candidat
de rassemblement qu'est alain juppé est
choisi par son temps par cette
compétition je le soutiendrai
j'essaierai auprès de lui de faire
valoir mes idées qui sont pas tout à
fait les mêmes que les siennes sur un
certain nombre de sujets mais je le
soutiendrai pourquoi parce que je pense
que le pays a besoin de rassemblement a
besoin de rassembleur et de
rassemblement à 1000% sincère pour le
soutenir
est ce que vous êtes à 1000% convaincu
qu'il peut l'emporter à la primaire jeu
est ce que comme vous l'avez compris le
faire en sorte comme vous l'avez compris
je trouve le mécanisme des primaires
risquez sinon dangereux écoutez vous
avez sous les yeux les primaires
américaines grand pays
le camp républicain important dans la
sensibilité du pays a joué un rôle
majeur dans dans son édification et bien
le camp républicain va être représentée
par donald trump
ça vous trouble pas ça veut ça vous pose
pas une question y'a pas dans votre
regard comme une interrogation comme une
interrogation c'est une machine qui est
une quête une machine c'est une
centrifugeuse et ça favorise les gens
les plus agressifs transgressif et
agressif c'est comme ça la prime à six
balles et transgressif aujourd'hui
l'actualité sera peut-être raison
excusez moi excusez moi monsieur goze je
voudrais je suis une précision absolue
je ne parle pas de nicolas sarkozy dans
cette affaire
je parle du mécanisme qui a été choisi
pour la compétition pour le candidat de
ce mot dans ce camp-là récemment par ce
candidat juppé ou sarkozy donc vous
voulez bien qu'on fasse une émission
ordonnée on va pas on va pas parler les
uns sur les autres
vos auditeurs n'y comprennent rien et
n'entendent rien alors essayons de
parler calmement les uns après les
autres
ce que je redoute c'est le mécanisme qui
a été choisi parce que c'est un
mécanisme qui n'est pas conforme aux
institutions de la vème république et à
leur esprit et qui électoralement et
risqué voilà tout ce que je dis est ce
qui se passe et ce que nicolas sarkozy
entraîne comme au mouvement va
exactement dans le sens que j'aime en
précise les choses
l'homme n'est pas seule responsable du
réchauffement climatique
nos ancêtres étaient gaulois ça va dans
le sens de la l'agressivité et la
transfusion
enfin vous voyez bien de quoi il s'agit
c'est une j'allais dire une stratégie
non c'est une tactique
qui est qui est grosse comme une maison
comme vous dites cousu de fil blanc ou
de câbles de marine comme on voudra
inquiet et qui est simple qui est plus
c'est gros plus on en parle plus ça
excite les passions et rapporte des voix
+ et transgressif par rapport à ce que
l'on essayé d'élaborer des gens qui
sérieusement réfléchissent à l'avenir du
pays
plus c'est choquant plus ça rapporte
alors dans sa dîme le pays sabine la
droite sa vie recenser ces risques et
voilà c'est dangereux je les dis depuis
suffisamment longtemps pour comme en
face crédit et donc de ce point de vue
là oui nicolas sarkozy a choisi une
stratégie qui est exactement parallèle à
la stratégie de donald trump et le fait
excuser moi de le dire avec plus de
crédibilité que trump mais vous entendez
ce qu'il dit mais qu'est ce que tu dis
moi je m'adresse pas seulement une
partie de la droite je m'adresse au
peuple et ceux qui liste fait partie des
préoccupations des français
l'immigration l'islam donc est ce que il
nomme les choses où est-ce qu'ils
transgressent si je pouvais souligné la
gravité de ce que je vais dire je le
ferai le peuple ce n'est pas ce que ces
gens disent qu'il est les aspirations du
peuple ne sont pas des aspirations à
détruire des choses précieuses qui ont
fait notre vie nationale les aspirations
du peuple c'est que on dise la vérité
est qu'on élève le débat
pas con le rabaisse le débat le peuple
que je prétend connaître mieux que
d'autres parce que il se trouve que j'ai
toute ma vie vécue je suis né j'ai vécu
au milieu de ce peuple là le peuple du
travail
les gens qui travaillent le peuple d
ceux qui essaient de travailler à
l'école le peuple de ceux qui créent des
petites entreprises artisanales
c'est le monde d'où je viens et où je
suis enraciné ce monde là il n'attend
pas qu on rabaisse perpétuellement le
débat il attend le contraire il attend
qu'il y ait en france
des responsables démocratique je n'ai
même pas des responsables politiques
vous comprenez des responsables
démocratique les gens il est de plus en
plus les gens à se portent des gens des
gens lorsque vous disiez puisque vous
disiez justement que ce que les
déclarations de nicolas sarkozy
ramener des voix donc ceci est autre
chose
la question de françoise fressoz c est
ce que c'est le peuple ce qui l'attend
ça je ne le crois pas c'est une partie
exaspérés des français dont on nourrit
l'exaspération
ça n'est pas pour moi la responsabilité
politique
jamais les hommes qui ont fait notre
histoire ne se sont comportés de la
sorte cette dreamhack comment un langage
un discours de raison à la paire si vous
vous êtes optimiste quand même vous
employer le mot de raison et pour moi ce
mot de raison ne suffit pas moi je suis
pour cette passion-là qui est une
passion en effet des des attentes des
citoyens du peuple français j'ai eu
comme j'ai eu au gouvernement la
responsabilité de l'éducation civique
je trouve que toute la vie démocratique
notre notre responsabilité c'est aussi
une responsabilité d'éducation civique
c'est pas de flatter toujours ce qu'il
ya de plus en flammes à bhl chez les
êtres humains pour y trouver un avantage
ou je crois le contraire
les questions civique c'est dire que
lorsqu'on devient français nos ancêtres
sont gaulois mais vous voyez bien c'est
n'importe quoi pourvu qu en cause un
c'est fait plus c'est gros et plus ça
fait du bruit et plus ça peut rapporter
2 des voix
monsieur bayrou quand nicolas sarkozy
et que lorsque l'on devient français nos
ancêtres sont les gaulois c'est vrai ça
veut dire il veut dire qu'on a des rapa
qui république il veut faire naître une
polémique parce qu'ils pensent que la
polémique apporte des voix il trouve
dans la polémique en faisant brûler un
sujet un carburant électorale mais quand
je dis c'est n'importe quoi pourvu qu'on
en parle pourvu qu'on en cause comme on
disait autrefois
qu'est ce que ça veut dire est ce que
vous imaginez qu'il ya un seul français
aujourd'hui dans les difficultés qui
sont les difficultés de la vie de tous
les jours
qui sont les difficultés du travail du
chômage des angoisses sociales les
problèmes réels de la vie des gens qui
se lèvent le matin en visant à ce qu'il
faut aujourd'hui c'est que j'affirme que
mes ancêtres sont gaulois non mais je
veux dire il est temps alors je sais
bien que cette vie politique est un est
un est un accélérateur à âneries
perpétuelle mais oh
il est temps qu'on ramène sur terre les
questions qui sont celles du débat
politique et qu'on arrête avec tous ceux
qui cherchent à faire flamber
l'excitation des plus excitables je ne
connais aucun français pour qui la
question des gaulois comme ancêtre soin
de vous assure une question qui à la
moindre importance et la moindre utilité
est ce que ce que je cherche c'est ce
que beaucoup en fait de deux citoyens
cherchent avec moi c'est que on parle
des problèmes qui sont les problèmes de
la vie des gens
et je dois ajouter une chose qui est
beaucoup plus grave encore c'est que la
france ça n'est pas une question
d'origine et du passé est de la race des
ancêtres ou de l'ethnie des ancêtres la
france c'est une question de ce que nous
voulons vivre et faire ensemble une
question d'idéal et de projets ça n'est
pas par le passé qu'on est français
seulement si c'était le cas il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ne qui n'en
seraient pas on est français par
l'adhésion à un projet beaucoup plus
grand que moi qui ont dit cette aventure
avec dans l'actualité ce débat cette
polémique autour de calais françoise
fressoz un mur est en train de s'ériger
pour essayer de protéger les accès du
port de calais contre les tentatives des
migrants de passer en grande-bretagne
est ce que vous vous approuvé la
construction de ce mur j'imagine que les
responsables qui ont pris cette décision
au gouvernement français et en
britannique
ses responsables là savent ce qu'ils
font
moi d'abord je veux dire quelque chose
qui n'est pas souvent dit je pense aux
calaisiens c'est à dire à ceux qui
partagent la partage la vie de cette
ville appartiennent à sa communauté et
qui sont si profondément blessée par ce
qui se passe autour de ce camp et je
trouve que les calaisiens mérite aussi
que qu'on réfléchisse à leur vie de tous
les jours et à leur sort et à ce que
hélas ils ont sous les yeux
ça c'est la première question la
deuxième question c'est que je conteste
la manière dont le gouvernement agit
pour la
suppression de ce camp le gouvernement
est en train de multiplier des centres
d'accueil en france l'autre jour dans
une émission du service public ge était
interrogé par un maire de la loire qui
racontait une histoire qui équipe est
vraiment émouvante
il le faisait avec des mots qui étaient
des mots très équilibré et très
responsable et très généreux il nous
racontait que au micro que il est à la
tête d'un village de 1300 habitants et
que le gouvernement sans rien lui
demander a décidé d'implanter dans ce
centre un centre d'accueil pour sans
réfugiés célibataires masculins sans
dans un village de 1300 habitants
vous croyez que ça peut aller et moi je
défends excusez moi moi je défends moi
je défends mais je défends une autre
méthode que le gouvernement indique le
nombre de réfugiés qu'il faudrait
prendre en charge dans un département
par exemple et qu'il ouvre le dialogue
avec les élus locaux avec les présidents
d'intercommunalités pour que ils
réfléchissent eux mêmes à la manière
dont il pourrait le mieux organiser la
crise pour moi je suis contre les
centres qui sont des centres de
concentration en fin de difficultés des
misères je suis pour qu'on réfléchisse à
mettre en place des accueils plus léger
en nombre pour que ça s'intègre mieux
accueillir 1700 1800 réfugier dans une
région de 7000 7 million deux cent mille
habitants comme le souhaite pas laurent
wauquiez présent deux régions
on allait bien sûr qu'on peut à
condition de demander aux élus locaux
leur
leur piste leurs idées ce qu'ils
proposent comment on peut faire
je suis sûr qu'ils sont tous prêts à
examiner cette question mais donnons
leur la responsabilité et l'initiative
ils connaissent mieux leur ville leur
commune leur leur région que ne le fait
l'état qui aveuglément à l'aveuglent
réparti les gens entre la pétition
lancée par laurent wauquiez justement
pour dire au maire n'accueillait pas ces
migrants puisqu'on veut pas se concerter
avec vous puisque l'étape où passent par
dessus et l'association qui a créé
steeve briois hénin beaumont qui est une
association qui a pour nom mairie cents
migrants communes 100 migrants quelle
différence entre laurent xavier bertrand
si on avait même parti que l'on invoqué
dit qu'il ne voit pas de différence mais
je veux pas entrer dans ce genre de
polémique parce que vous voyez bien que
la question devient une question
électorale c'est pas mon avis mon avis
c'est un nous avons un problème
évidemment de concentration inacceptable
et de conditions de vie inacceptables
2 si on doit le résoudre faisons le dans
la concertation et la collaboration avec
les élus locaux qui sont des hommes de
terrain et des responsables de terrain
et ils auront eu plus d'imagination et
je crois de générosité et de sensibilité
à la réalité du terrain que l'état
central qui avec une espèce de bandeau
sur les yeux décide de manière
autoritaire des décisions des jld les
terrains mais comprenez moi nous sommes
prêts les élus locaux sont prêts à aller
vite à condition qu'on respecte la
responsabilité qui est la leur et la
connaissance du terrain qu'elano naquit
emilie locale
élu tout court et qui dans la voie
sociale 30 dans le cadre de cette pré
campagne présidentielle c'est emmanuel
macron frédéric dumoulin vie ressemble à
toutes les discussions donc vous voyez
un peu comme mesure tout comme macron
vous avez même dit vous même c'est le
candidat des forces de l'argent ça un
peu surpris cette attaque assez
virulente
est ce qu'en fait macron vous inquiète
en rien emmanuel macron c'est le
principal responsable de la politique
économique a été suivie par françois
hollande depuis quatre ans deux ans
comme conseiller spécial secrétaire
général adjoint de l'elysée chargé de
l'économie et deux années comme ministre
de l'économie et donc ça sa
responsabilité est très grande et depuis
ces deux années là il ya des choses qui
sont extrêmement évidente les choix qui
ont été faits vont à l'encontre sur
beaucoup de sujets des choix que je
crois nécessaire et les résultats sont
catastrophiques en beaucoup de
centristes sont séduits aujourd'hui
votre ami sur le bourlanges
françois bayrou se sent menacé et ça se
voit l'affichage de cette inquiétude il
sa critique de toute crédibilité semble
donc très bien laissons-les sont les
mots excessifs à leur place c'est pas
mon point de vue quel a été le fil
directeur sur lequel je me suis opposé à
la politique en particulier à la
politique qui a été suivi le fil
directeur c'est premièrement lippert
fiscalisation les 75%
j'avais employer une formule qui était
un peu lestes j'avais dit le d'économie
m fonctionne à plein tube que le jour où
cette formule a été sous l'inspiration
des mêmes
forme formulée c'était évident que ça ne
marcherait pas que ça serait
catastrophique
c'est cela qui est arrivé deuxièmement
si vous regardez les différentes lois qu
est ce qui est frappant
ce qui est frappant c'est que la
rémunération du travail est toujours
amputé que la volonté c'est l'amputation
de la rémunération du travail en moi je
crois que la rémunération du travail est
insuffisante en france je parle pas du
coût du travail
je parle de ce que le salarié reçoit
alors les heures supplémentaires amputer
le la comment dirais-je le la
rémunération du travail du dimanche
amputé constamment on a le sentiment que
ce gouvernement comme d'autres ont
toujours voulu abaisser la rémunération
du travail notamment dans le maine
déraillé mais quand même à niveau de
déficit énorme donc françois hollande
dit bon j'ai peut-être augmenter les
impôts mais je les ai réduit
vous avez maintenant la droite qui
revient au pouvoir et qui dit pendant
deux ans je laisser filer les déficits
ça c'est sérieux ou pas au moelleux se
trompe gravement mais je veux dire toute
annonce qui dit dans les années qui
viennent
la tension au déficit c'est fini on va
de nouveau faire du déficit
enfin de nouveau aggravé les déficits
qu'on n'a même pas réussi à ramener au
dessous des 3% je vous rappelle que le
plan que françois hollande avait annoncé
ces on revient au dessous de 3 % la
première année et en 2010 est on sera on
est à l'équilibré d'après les prévisions
alex est oui bah moi je j'attends de
voir les voiliers les jca dit il faut
investir en pétard et donc en forçant
tous les to alors maintenant au sein de
la primaire de la droite pour multiplier
les annonces et les promesses ont dit
nous avec nous c'est fini on s'en fiche
on a déjà connu ça nicolas sarkozy en
2007 a fait ça inquiète les responsables
politiques allemands sont inquiètes mais
l'europe va être dans si l'on suivait
cette politique
il y aura en europe où il y aurait en
europe une crise majeure
si on s'arrête une seconde l'europe la
construction européenne l'idée
européenne sont hague en grave danger
voyez vous c'est pas souvent dans ma vie
mais pour la première fois j'ai le
sentiment que la dislocation peut
arriver à cause du bric situe à cause de
l'attitude des pays bas à cause du mur
exit à cause de la divergence des
politiques économiques menées en europe
je crois sans doute même que un certain
nombre de responsables cherchent la
dislocation lesquels ben vous voyez bien
les thèses défendues par le front
national c'est faut sortir de l'euro et
sortir de l'europe faut sortir de
l'union européenne je considère que ce
serait à mahler historique
je pense que en face de la chine
en face des états unis si l'union
européenne qui avait réussi à créer un
môle 2 2 d'un fluence et de
d'affirmations forte autour d'un modèle
de société
si l'union européenne se disloquait ce
serait un drame pour nous tous et je
vois venir me temps où à force de ne
jouer que des intérêts électoraux
alors oui on est il est envisageable
il est possible que la dislocation
interviennent et donc ces affirmations
sont pour moi des affirmations
irresponsable affirmation aussi autre
affirmation dans le cadre de la primaire
et vous voyez la gravité de ce qu'on
vient d'en évoquer l'arrêt dans le cas
de la primaire de la droite
on nous dit 85 milliards d'euros
d'économies est ce que c'est parce que
c'est faisable parce que c'est possible
ce que vous le souhaitez mais vous voyez
bien le la schizophrénie la
schizophrénie c'est on va faire 80 100
milliards d'euros d'économie jeu murray
qu'on me dise ou parce que c'est pas
facile c'est une tâche extrêmement
lourdes est en même temps laissera filer
les déficits
quelle logique qu'il ya dans cette
affaire eh bien je dis moi que oui je
trouve que l'expression d'un certain
nombre de ceux qui se présentent à cette
élection n'est pas responsable
on met un jeu que tout le monde est
paumé on met en jeu des choses on met en
jeu des choses extrêmement graves que
tout le monde soit peau mais c'est
possible mais qu'il le dise
alain juppé il fait partie des gens non
non non je pense que le plus responsable
de tous
en tout cas un des plus responsables de
tous c'est alain juppé par notre voie
qu'il est d'abord puisque vous avez été
misés ducation vous avez rappelé aux
questions françoise fressoz ce qui
nourrit l'éducation qui revient en force
dans la campagne et notamment la mise de
l'éducation qui annonce qu'elle voudrait
dans le cadre de la prochaine campagne
électorale mettre en débat
l'école obligatoire de trois ans à 18
ans alors qu'aujourd'hui elle est
obligatoire de 6 à 16 ans lutter contre
deux chargeurs c'est crédible pour vous
est ce que c'est une bonne idée dans ces
graves mais toute l'action
toute l'action qui a été celle du
ministère de l'éducation ces dernières
années c'est une action qui porte
atteinte à un certain nombre de choses
extrêmement importantes est extrêmement
précieuse est ce que vous croyez il ya
un grand nombre de jeunes français qui
soit soit en apprentissage soit pas
sensé ap soit passe un bep pour entrer
dans la vie professionnelle à 16 ans
parce que simplement ils supportent pas
l'école comme elle est et après tout
c'est absolument légitime ils vont
trouver un métier ils vont trouver une
fierté professionnelle et après ils
auront tout loisir et j'espère qu'on
leur fournir à cette possibilité de
retrouver le formation de reprendre un
chemin de formation ou pas parce que
peut-être ils seront très contents de
cela
et l'idée qu' il faudrait à tout prix
ces jeunes là les maintenir dans le
cadre d'une institution scolaire pour
faire plaisir à une expression syndicale
moi j'ai beaucoup de respect pour le
snese pas sur ces mesures
comment dirais-je corporatiste à parce
que mais j'aimais le snes business est
un est un syndicat qui souvent expriment
des choses profondes
sauf quand ce sont des partis pris
idéologiques comme celui là mais c'est
de la m l'école obligatoire plus tôt
c'est-à-dire de traiter la petite
enfance à est ce que c'est une bonne
orientation bonne orientation
parce que les problèmes de deux
d'inégalité sociale et culturelle
commence très très tôt à condition de
réinventer aussi ou de suggérer une
réinvention de l'école maternelle il ya
des expériences qui sont conduites ces
temps ci que je trouve très heureuse
parce que si vous regardez la disparité
de niveau par exemple de langage entre
les enfants
alors vous vous dites que oui il faut
intervenir très tôt en mai cette cette
mesure démagogique et d'ist très loin de
la réalité scolaire qui consisterait à
maintenir à tout prix les jeunes dans le
système scolaire alors même qu'ils
veulent trouver un chemin d'inscription
professionnels pour en sortir
c'est désastreux comme comme irréaliste
mais comme les aussi lié aussi à
l'éducation à l'enseignement
une partie de la droite est également
tirée mandon veulent imposer la
sélection à l'entrée des universités ce
que sinon c'est bas la sélection à
l'entrée de l'université
excusez moi c'est la sélection ou en
tout cas une liberté pour les
universités de m un examen enfin une
vérification des connaissances et des
fondamentaux dans le cours de
l'université notamment au master c'est à
dire
bac + 4 + 5 et moi je trouve qu'il ya
aucune raison qu'on en parle pas qu'on
discute pas de cette affaire cette année
pour les staps c'est à dire l'éducation
physique et sportive
il y a dix sept mille cinq cents places
je parle de chiffres grossier enfin
grosso modo et il y à 27 milles 500
candidats que fait-on à ont fait la
sélection mais vraiment la sélection la
plus stupide et injuste possible on tire
au sort alors si quelqu'un veut venir
sur ce plateau soutenir que le tirage au
sort c'est mieux que la vérification des
connaissances
alors je le jeu relève et je trouve que
tout ceci mais vous voyez à quel point
on marche sur la tête
on va par le le le le débat politique
est en train de perdre
absolument tout son équilibre à notre
tirage au sort le tirage au sort la
présidentielle frédéric dumoulin quand
on vous écoute vous êtes prêt en fait
vous est prévu qui a dit que je n'étais
pas prêt mais voilà il se trouve que
vous ne pourrez pas échapper à nantes il
se trouve que en effet j'ai une vision
je crois assez cohérente et je crois
assez juste mais ça c'est évidemment
chacun qu'ils pensent ce qu'ils pensent
juste mais qui croit qu'il pense juste
j'ai une vision de l'avenir du pays
j'ai défendues depuis des années des
idées et des thèses qui se sont avérées
vérifier dans la plupart des caps par la
réalité
y compris quand j'étais seul contre tous
un sur les affaires par exemple sur la
privatisation des autoroutes à un
scandale de plus je me suis battu
souvent seuls et je crois assez juste
sur les déficits sur la dette / etc
ils ont sur une certaine idée de la vie
publique en france de l'honnêteté de la
vie publique
de l'impartial où sont gardées bio
closer nom de nom de la page
demandez moi quand vous savez au talent
oui ok mais est ce que je le sors en
octobre chez temps dont vous sentez
après les primaires on verra et donc la
question est la question est celle là
dans cette vie politique complètement
déséquilibré la vision que je défends je
la crois cohérente je la crois juste et
je pense qu'elle peut apporter une
réponse à un certain nombre de français
mais j'ai choisi pour montrer après tout
la volonté de rassemblement qu'est la
mienne que si un candidat de rente de
rassemblement était proposée par une
autre famille politique j'étais prêt à
soutenir
est-ce que cependant j'ai abandonné le
travail de de préparation de réflexion
de formulation nom et avec elle et avec
quelles troupes autour de haut avec des
troupes nombreuses et cohérente si vous
venez ce week-end à guidel vous avez les
voir entendez marine le pen déclaré sur
rtl que les grands choix qu'elles
portent sont désormais majoritaires en
france qu'il n'y a pas de plafond de
verre et quand vous la voyez essayer
d'apaiser son discours est ce que vous
vous dites c'est pas quand même un grand
danger est ce qu'elle peut l'emporter
mon jugement résume le front national et
sur sa présidente est simple je pense
deux choses la première des choses que
je pense et que ce les solutions ou les
propositions qui sont portées par ce
courant politique et sa candidate
son je pèse mes mots mortel pour le pays
pas nuisible pas approximative mortel
pour le pays parce que l'orientation qui
consiste à dire nous allons tout lâché
remettre tous les acquis sociaux comme
il l'était il ya 40 ans et d'ailleurs
c'est facile parce que nous nous en
sortirons
en sortant de l'euro en créant une
monnaie nationale pour lever en sortant
de l'europe cela est mortel pour le pays
et c'est un combat que je ne cesserai
pas de mener
la deuxième chose ce qui avantage
considérablement le front national s'est
il n'est pas représenté dans le cadre de
la vie publique et qu'il y a pas
seulement le front national il y à 60%
des français 6 sur 10 des français
extrême gauche extrême droite et centre
indépendant qui ne sont pas représentés
la vie politique dont on n'a aucun
intérêt et aucun c'est long c'est à
l'avant ce qu'ils vont dire donc plus
personne ne s'en occupe et ça nourrit le
front national elle est une réunion
l'opposant universel et c'est qu'on en
effet le change on arrive à la demande
arrive à la fin de l'émission
pratiquement on vous a parlé de françois
lenglet faisant la république
sa coque reste très basse très très
basse et pourtant il vient de se voir
décerner le prix de l'homme d'état de
l'année à new york vous si vous
comprenez ou pas c'est l'homme d'état de
l'année vont se révélant sera l'invité
plus tard non je pense que que l'intérêt
dès la fin 2013 je pense que françois
hollande a renoncé à porter les grands
changements que la situation du pays
exigeait et il a même renoncé à la
fonction à le haut au caractère le plus
le plus important de la fonction
présidentielle qui est celui de porter
une vision historique de l'avenir du
pays il y à renoncer sauf par exemple
dans son intervention au mali je les ai
soutenus pour son intervention au mali
parce que dans l'action politique il ya
toujours des chapitres qui méritent
d'être soutenus et d'autres qui méritent
d'être critiqué mais le bilan général de
l'action de françois hollande nous
l'avons sous les yeux et les français ne
s'y trompe pas je pense que il a
lui-même renoncer au caractère marquant
qui est peu qui aurait pu être celui de
l'ancien camp hollande c'est fini et je
dis plus que ça je dis que l'enjeu
principal de l'élection présidentielle
qui vient c'est que la vie publique
française la vie politique la vie
démocratique française soir bâti sur des
bases nouvelles
on ne cherche pas
une restauration de ce qu'ils avaient
avant tout cas moi cherche pas du tout
avant on ne cherche pas une prolongation
de ce qui existe aujourd'hui nous
cherchons une reconstruction une ré
invention de la vie publique en france
et de la démocratie en france et je ne
cesserai pas de me battre succession sur
la campagne ce sera plus facile ce
serait plus facile contre françois
hollande ont contre emmanuel macron non
mais je veux dire de génie de
franchement si vous n'avez pas écouté ce
que je dis je me suis opposé à la
politique économique de françois
hollande tout le temps je me suis opposé
à la volonté constamment de 2 de porter
atteinte par exemple revenus du travail
de ceux qui sont au boulot et vous venez
me dire que c'est mon créneau c'est
c'est la politique de que le
gouvernement a suivi
je me suis opposé je vais pas
aujourd'hui laissé entendre ou laisser
croire que ce soit le même courant et
donc de toute façon cette hypothèse à
mes yeux je peux me tromper n'existe pas
et on verra au contraire le françois
hollande
je crois qu'il ne peut pas faire
autrement que de se présenter malgré les
très graves handicaps qu'ils sont les
siens et qu'il a lui-même voulu qu'il a
lui-même voulu et de ce point de vue là
en effet je proposerai soit comme allié
soit directement devant les français une
autre voie merci merci conscience à
leurs phases de questions d'info
merci d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
et bien c'est à vous de nous être
fidèles la semaine prochaine vers sic